[Music]
honestly i have to do a huge congrats to
anthony lee right now he has a shoe with
[ __ ] nike launching dude called the
air sesh air sesh it's coming when
uh beginning of next year
dance shoe ever right ever designed uh i
won't say it's the first dance shoe but
it for for street dancing uh and
especially with nike yeah it's like the
first of its kind that way dance this is
nike's first dance shoe yeah they made a
uh classical ballet attempt uh one time
and it didn't it wasn't really a push
but i think the the difference is uh one
of the major conversations that we had
was like you can't
encapsulate everything about the dance
culture into one shoe so many people
dance in different ways and dancers
already are stylistically fickle like
you have one pair and then you move on
it doesn't really matter anyway but um
when we were in that major conversation
with tinker it was kind of like i had
said that i was like we can't just make
one shoe and like call this the dance
representation but he was like
sometimes especially for the powers that
be that are higher up that make calls
you know what i'm saying they need
something to start with yeah so like the
shoe was at the end one of many it's
just a start to a broader dance
dimension and representation of the
culture and so amongst that plus like
the push of like breaking going into the
olympics in paris in 2024 like the the
culture right now is every dance is
going to the olympics it's that thing
amazing
was in the olympics oh it's a breakdown
no no b-boying a b-girl break-in is in
the olympics for the first time 2024. oh
i think bart's thinking of the
nutcracker yeah yeah no they were candy
you seen you you saw it at like junior
olympic qualifiers or something like
that but to officially become a part of
the major uh summer olympics
you see all those kids that crushed it
in japan yeah dude yeah like the kids
the 13 year olds and whatnot that like
won everything dude x games is over huh
it's over
i think so i mean there's olympics now
unless well x games can play every year
though yeah so they'll be the
in-betweens
so for this shoes that you have what
makes it um like a dance shoe like
what's the special for sure for sure um
we put
first i think one of the coolest things
is i remember flexibility needing to be
a huge point so we when we had the test
shoes i remember thinking like uh these
aren't these aren't flexible enough like
they feel like they push it back to the
ground but we need to like be able to
see on our toes at times and we're in
innovation literally uh one of the main
uh vps of the innovation side richard
she goes out she grabs a box cutter she
runs back in she's like where do you
need more flexibility we're like uh
right here
and then she takes the shoe and she
[ __ ] cuts the sole oh the box cutter
and then now it just opens she cuts the
second line and then it opens even
farther and like we tried on we're like
okay that's a lot better and now for the
first time in nike shoes there are those
two slashes at the bottom of the sole
for flexibility
and asia there's kids just cutting the
shoes with box cutters you just cut them
with boxes yeah yeah they stab them yeah
or like there's a there's um there's a
type of rubber on the bottom of the shoe
on the front side like right here and
here one is specifically more grip and
one is more slick so that you can coupe
and spin or you can stop depending on
how you control it
wow
there's a glow and dark nike on the sign
on the bottom on the bottom yeah dude
they should make some off-road shoes
they should get tire rubber there with
spikes and put it on the bottom i think
they do i think those are acg's
oh yeah the all-country gear yeah they
go all country all conditions yeah all
country gear is better all country gear
sounds like some off-road [ __ ] all
country music the cat who did dare
jordan's ticker hatfield what was that
like that was amazing that was like um
that was like seeing like a hero and
then not knowing how to react did you
ask him what his favorite color was yeah
that's a good question that's good
it's a pertinent question who here
doesn't know who tinker hatfield is i
literally don't but i'm but i'm sorry
i'm not very pissed brief history you
give a brief history because you know
uh so i know a little bit but um he
out of all of the most famous jordans
that you know that you know that are
legendary that have the crazy programs
huh pearl greens earl grace i don't know
graves whatever
he designed all of them and each one of
them
it's
the
epitome of form and function but also
tying in
like
legacy of jordan so one of the shoes
um like he would sit there watch
jordan's games and he see and he's like
he plays like he's a fighter jet like he
comes in and crushes it so like what you
know the old school like world war ii
planes where there's like the teeth on
the side
like that's how uh that's where he would
put that part into it or if or he has
like he's won the cement
the the concrete elephant skin cement uh
kind of on the red and black and gray
yeah yeah yeah
like that was also like a a feature that
he just pulled like out of inspiration
and that was like something that was
considered crazy at the time but you did
that it's just yes a bunch of iconic
story into every single shoe and when
you're designing like designing shoes is
very similar to designing cars where
you're always trying to find that
perfect match of form versus function
yeah because the most aerodynamic car is
gonna look ugly as [ __ ] and then the
most functional car is gonna i mean the
most aerodynamic car yeah it's gonna
look ugly as [ __ ] and the most uh
functional car is also gonna look ugly
so you want it to
look sexy but also be functional and
same thing with the shoe wow and he's
just like on another level in terms of
like if you think of jordans like any
subsect of any brand that has
almost outgrown the brand itself there's
no other shoe on the planet it's like he
made sneakers popular pretty much like
he made can you do me a favor though
like don't shack this up don't charge
like nine dollars for your shoes or
whatever because that's what makes them
uncool i think they're gonna be 110
that's too accessible i'm in dude i'll
buy three pairs that's a decent price
point though no converse used to be dirt
[ __ ] cheap man that shit's almost 100
bucks now
really yeah
for like 20 bucks a chuck a regular
chuck taylor is a hundred bucks
yeah oh i was like no [ __ ] way dude
dude if you wear toms nobody will even
steal them off your feet yeah dude yeah
but i remember when chucks were like
they're so ugly 20 bucks
it was 20 dollars that was also there's
like inflation though
that i mean come on man it's it's canvas
shoes with a soul what speaking of
they're almost [ __ ] kung fu shoes i
think i think
they're functional kung fu shoes
i think this would be cool if you're
into sneakers in terms of understanding
inspiration colorway and design and
stuff um nike was really really
one of the most powerful stories at the
very inception in the beginning of nike
was it was always about running in the
very beginning yeah and uh bill bauerman
phil knight the two guys that started
nike like they was blue ribbon sports
back then right it was blue room sports
i was the first store i think it was in
santa monica which is actually where we
shot one of our videos so they have beer
and shoes yep top split ribbon
what's going on
there's a container unloading out how's
that yeah do we need to wait or not yeah
we should
really that's a wild reverberation bro
okay all right so blue ribbon yeah so
from an inspiration design and colorway
standpoint um with nike like it always
started with running for them and they
were always about listening to athlete
they were like selling running shoes out
of their vans when they would go to like
track meets and stuff like that right
and uh one thing that uh i believe it
was bill bauerman who did uh was it phil
knight either one of them one of the
things that they did was they wrote a
manual
called
i think jogging because at the time
jogging didn't exist so what was what
was this is crazy jogging was invented
in the 1900s
by the founders of nike and the reason
why
i know it's [ __ ] ridiculous right yes
and the reason why they invented it was
because there were a lot of like
professional athletes when they would uh
prime themselves and run at such a high
athletic level if they stopped running
like purely stopped and as they got
older they would actually run into like
physical defects and like disabilities
and stuff or their bodies would break
down because they had to go through such
rigorous training at one point and then
suddenly not at all so the infection
arnold schwarzenegger saggy titties
exactly why just stop lifting dude so so
they invented jogging to keep at that
time
uh former athletes in a type of healthy
and safe state while they got older and
started retiring
so the idea of jogging and why that's
powerful is that it wasn't necessarily
about like
the best in the game
jogs it's like everyone can jog and it's
something that's a access and entry
point for everybody and that's why they
chose the original cortez because that
was a colorway of red white and blue to
put on this dance shoe as well because
the intention is not only to create the
best athletes of dancers and the best
dancers in the world it's supposed to be
a clear entry point because everybody
can dance in today's world everybody
through social media tick tock our
generation everybody dances in one one
way or another you know whether you're a
professional or you just enjoy it and
the whole point to connect the colorway
of the original cortez is to relate
dancing to today's jogging and america
i don't know about that but i did find
the video there we go oh my gosh oh
our friend anthony on nike.com
wow that is so cool
[Music]
today's video is brought to you by
curology
people there is no shame in the game
especially you basement dwelling smelly
dudes out there i know i was once one of
you when i was 13 years old didn't take
a shower for a week and washing my face
consisted of spl splashing my face in
the sprinkler when i when the sprinklers
were on in the front door on the front
lawn
skin care can be actually pretty cool
because when you see the results of what
it can do to your face you transform
something it becomes a work of art okay
sometimes you can't fix ugly but you
could beautify it as much as you can and
that's why curology is pretty awesome
they sent me a kid because they're like
yo joe i know you got
skin
goals i know you want anti-aging
wrinkles whatever like you want to deal
with this stuff you got dry skin i got
you it's a pretty
easy way of figuring out what is the
best type of formula for me it's
customized and they can do that for you
too let's say you want to do something
without your acne pimples whatever they
have a licensed dermatology provider
that's going to help you on your journey
and they're going to help you pick and
choose maybe you need this maybe you
need that who knows right i figured out
my formula and then they sent me a
personalized kit it was really awesome i
got face wash in there that's awesome i
got my special joe cream
and um i got a moisturizer because you
know i want to keep it moisturized yeah
and that's why they're awesome because
it's specially formulated for you by a
licensed dermatology provider so
if you're born and for some reason you
have shades on your face like a raccoon
and you're like i need to get rid of
this they can help you with dark spots
and all of that too so make sure you go
to curology.com off the record to get a
free 30-day trial in one month a lot can
happen especially if you stick to a skin
care regimen make sure to curology
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash off the
record to get your free 30-day trial are
you wearing the shoes yes he's wearing a
shirt no when did the shoes come out
next year that is where can i get the
outfit
i need more shoes okay
how come you guys didn't ask us to be in
the video tinkers look at he's wearing
our jacket and our hat and stuff like
that that's incredible as baby that's
our newest crew mate
wow
those shoes are cool
you could spin in those things you ever
tell your mom like go to nike.com she's
like i don't care man what the hell
they like that though there's literally
like i i honestly will get a pair of
shoes for my my dad or something talk to
me when you're on louisvilletown.com
dude
dude i'll never get my mom out of here
bro kids is her [ __ ] dude
this is crazy that's so sick wow are
they all wearing it
they better be
i'll wear it and tell you if it's good
for dancing
we have to you know what we should do
he's wearing her guys merch man
it's crazy you have to pay me not to
wear these [ __ ] things so i'll bring
your [ __ ] brand down dude
you guys should dress [ __ ] steve up
as a kenja and then have them perform
with you guys man
i'm just really we should all coach us
in dancing and we see who has the best
dance
yeah and this
honestly this is still blowing my mind
because this just came out like
literally in the last two days that's
sick and we just got approval finally
today to talk about and post it so
kendra just posted today and that's
crazy because it looks dope we started
this journey with them four years ago
and honestly like let's be real when we
started four years ago nobody expected
it to get to this point yeah no way and
it's awesome
yeah it's also one of things where you
kind of pinch yourself because they're
like uh
i don't know let's hope for the best and
see what's you don't want to get your
hopes up because it's too crazy you know
what i like about it it's it's i like
classic looks yes and i like because i
don't like that fancy [ __ ] i don't wear
any jordans or nothing like that um
and i usually just get classic like
tennis shoes
and it looks comfortable and you could
you could go everywhere with it
now those are the cuts
the glow-in-the-dark swoosh if i put
those on can i automatically moonwalk
okay here we go
you'll you'll see when you try to do
stuff you're gonna be like oh
i can't wait to wear these dudes
damn look at that [ __ ] dude
that's really cool dude i could kick
somebody in the face with that they're
really fun you should try fighting with
it dude when i when i was watching it
earlier i was like dude you could
probably do anything yeah you probably
can dude you could probably box
something you could do anything okay so
you're creating the shoe right you have
to have a finalized design eventually
but like this is a big deal you're gonna
be on nike.com all this stuff big shoe
how do you go like okay it's really done
now what makes you give the get the
confidence to go i'm done [ __ ] it no
more no more revisions no more to be
completely honest we were um we were
lead consultants on it but we don't get
to make those calls and and and the
crazy thing is
if there's anything that we learned nike
is so big
that it's like of
the people that you know pull strings of
the people that you have to answer to or
the way things need to get approved or
like like even from day one it's like
it's almost like we got in with the
[ __ ]
the the art club or the scientists of
the of the school wow you know i mean it
wasn't like the principals and the head
people it was like the people that are
like wow we really appreciate art and we
want to see what we can do so every
single time uh we it's almost like you
passed the next test you had to re-prove
and re-explain everything about what you
were doing to the next tier wow who's
important because i remember the very
very first the re-pitch and re-pitch and
re-pitch the very first time we were
sitting with tinker it felt like we were
pitching him
so and and i remember specifically like
the nervousness where and the shakiness
and
maybe i wasn't shaking my voice but i
wasn't my spirit trying to look this
dude in the eye and be like yo like
to be honest we're always trying to
elevate the game of dance to let people
know how important dance is to our lives
and that it's a sport it's not just like
an art it's you're both an artist and an
athlete but like dance is our sport
right and he's kind of like
all right i see what you're saying
right and then years later this past
year went to an innovation meeting and
then he's
in the [ __ ] lead innovation and he's
doing a full presentation with
powerpoints videos of us we're about to
get on and perform in the new shoe
that's finalized and then we hear him
with all of global nike around the world
tuning in to listen to this internal
presentation a giant video conference
yeah giant education six thousand people
or something like that six thousand and
and he's like and it's crazy because
we're we're warming up and we're getting
ready to go out with a q but before this
queue he goes
dance is a sport
and bro all of us [ __ ] have the crazy
chills because like four years later you
guys cry
i wanted to but you know i know [ __ ]
it's a happy start
it was honestly so powerful you know and
like just to just to feel like we made
progress in the shadows like people
might never ever know yeah you know the
the complexity or how much work you put
in to get something as basic as once you
again this shouldn't answer dances
problems or questions or anything like
that it's just a starting point of a
conversation but to even like get it to
that point how much like sacrifice
dedication and time had to be put in and
then to hear tinker like say what you
had pitched him four years ago it's like
it's the most a bts cam following this
whole journey like this we could put on
a mini documentary later all of it we do
have a lot of stuff but again now he's
so big we don't have approval to post so
much do you ever go tinker because his
name is tinker do you call him tinker
tinky what's up
for tinkerbell do you go like
like
do you wear hats because the name or
like you know like because these guys
wear his hats he's [ __ ] tight tinker
hat field wears hats is it because like
is it part of his brand like that's part
of the anthony libra designers always
dress so damn well they do they just got
that eye dude like fedora he kind of
dresses like anthony lee
he looks like he
you're stuffed like he stole your dance
is a sport he stole your style he stole
your hat he stole your shoe design this
guy's just the art thief dude
that's hard this guy [ __ ] hard
the best artists are thieves
that's true
but i'm still not gonna say that about
this guy's a man so yeah no but um
talking to him you said you met him with
him a couple times right yeah a few
times what was that like is your dick
like shriveled up the first time you see
him
you get like your [ __ ] balls actually
like creative around him i genuinely i
genuinely you know i'm talking about
like when somebody's uh this type of
person when this is in front of you
right everything that they say it
doesn't [ __ ] matter you're just like
please keep talking
man legendary that's like the most
expensive shoe i guess that he designed
oh is that the uh the derek jeter
i swear to god that's what it's called
i'm not even kidding look at it shut up
i swear to god i'm not getting how is
that the most expensive there's jordan
11 retro premium derek jeter follow the
colorway [ __ ] oh
god damn it just because i cry wolf all
day long everything
everything's a cry wolf now too
complete [ __ ] dude but that's
[ __ ] huge man that's really [ __ ]
cool that's [ __ ] crazy
the first step is probably the hardest
step to make right
how long did it take though like
to get to this to release it four years
four years four years [ __ ]
and the shoe drops january january 22.
some of these things have been cooking
for quite some time with multiple times
where the project could have been
scrapped
wow multiple times here
i think like i said like we never
expected it to go all the way the fact
that we're here i'm like [ __ ] mind
blown to be completely honest it's still
surreal like whoa yeah i'm not i haven't
fully processed anything like i'm still
at the end of the day i'm still here if
i like every single time a video cuts i
look at [ __ ] and i'm like oh my god
does jordan get something for for being
part of air
i literally don't know not air no no
jordan has jordan yeah oh you see but
not error which is a nice subsidiary so
i guess he wasn't a good businessman
after all
so is air jordan
a collaboration between no air is just a
a department or or a just a thing with a
nike they have the air maxes their
sashes the air vapor maxes like they
have a bunch of air stuff in general
jordan is a completely separate like
yeah yeah but don't they have air
jordans they do they do yeah so is that
a collab separate from jordan's it was
the air jordan when nike was making it
before jordan had jordan brand
i like the shoes were red white and blue
[ __ ] america
i don't know how to go baby match red
white and blue shoes but i'll make it
what happens you can match up with
anything i think and he said it's coming
out other color ways too oh here we go
here we go
wow
i'm gonna spin like that dude yo it
looks like you gotta spin like that a
classic k-swiss and a cortez had a baby
i love cortez's green bottoms they're
glow in the dark but
that's cool as [ __ ] swoosh oh yeah you
said big longer that's really cool
because because a lot of times before
dancers are kicking each other in the
head during the dark dark yeah when the
lights go out you can't see you know you
know it's ironic there's um something
slightly maybe from a personal pace uh
there's something slightly bittersweet
about it uh maybe because
it took four years to get there but at
the same time in taking four years like
that's literally like i started when
what was i like 31 now i'm 35. you know
what i mean you think about like a prime
athlete imagine like a 35 euro player in
the nba doesn't mean they're not they
can't be [ __ ] phenomenal or useful
but like the [ __ ] 20 year old's going
off right now physically you know
dominating the sport and that's the same
thing that goes on even with dance right
there's 18 19 20 21 year olds that are
like killing the game doing the most
impossibly phenomenal things that are
you know like learned like fighting
right it's like you learn [ __ ] from
generations but you're an og though
you're an og and sometimes
you right now the og's uh has to put the
shots on but the bitter sweetness is
like we finally got danced to a place
where it's like you know i dream of
dance being on like espn i'm i probably
i think i like tweeted about this like
years ago i was like y'all one day
people might not believe but we're going
to get dance to the espn we're going to
let people like look at it in a totally
different pokers on espn they're just
sitting down exactly that's an athlete
for a long long time so to get into a
place where it's like we we're finally
starting to make noise but at the same
time being at like kind of the tail end
of my physical prime in my career
again i might still be a creative
director and still be a choreographer or
involved in dance in many many ways but
to be at like my top level athletic
performance i'm like i'm
i'm waning you know i'm coming down on
that you know i'm setting the tone and
you're um
offering something of value to the
culture
i appreciate it but he wants to be the
star that's the bitter sweetness my bad
i'm saying i want to be this but that's
the bittersweetness it's just feeling
like
ah like our
our time's almost done but at least
we're like finally doing something he's
the ron jeremy directing but he wants to
be the porn star [ __ ] yeah
i want to be there not over here
but but sometimes ron jeremy has to get
in front of the camera and show him what
time is enough we'll just get like uh
later that's later all right we're not
talking about that
dude
i actually really do uh genuinely mean
this in a way you're like the non-shim
of shoes oh my god
oh my god
that's pretty crazy man
[Music]
[Music]
you